hey what is happening this is John
Delaney with Ramsey Network it's awesome
to see you again
so I've been getting blown up with all
of your emails and I don't even know
what blown-up means other than like a
bomb going off but the the kids with the
youtubes and instagrams say that that
means that lots of people are doing a
thing so we're getting blown up with all
of your emails that ask John at Ramsey
solutions comm we've been taking some of
those calls to answer them on the Dave
Ramsey show we've been answering on one
of my new show that we're working on
that we're building up from the floor up
and I wanted to talk about some of the
emails that have come in today so check
it out we're gonna go over a couple I'm
gonna keep keep the names confidential
because I haven't called you and let you
know we're gonna talk about this but I
think these are some emails that
everybody wants to know are the people
across the country are dealing with
right now
number one when should a parent who was
cheated on by another parent tell their
kids that their husband or wife cheated
on them and that's where they got
divorced answer never never why would
you need to tell your kids what happened
you can tell them that me me and your
dad me and your mom we had we were
different people back then and we made
some transitions and we're better off
friends or we went through some hard
things and we decided that this was the
best route for our family but to a run
down somebody's mother or to run down
somebody's dad doesn't do anything but
make you feel better for a minute
because the real question there is not
when do I need to tell their kids what
their mom or their dad did so that they
can know but it's I want to make sure
that they know I was the good guy in
this situation not them and they don't
ever need to know that you know why
because your self-esteem your value as a
mom your value as a dad isn't dependent
on the feelings of a 7 year old or a 9
year old or a 13 year old your job is to
be the grown-up to be the adult and the
best way to do that is by honoring your
kids mom honoring your kid's dad and
we're talking about about them because
no matter how not good at relationships
they were they will always be your kids
mom or your kids dad talk about each
other with grace there's no reason to
ever get into the details of why your
marriage didn't work with your children
nope nope nobody's gonna do it okay okay
so email number two I don't pick me up
okay
so email number two um here we go let's
go down to this one looks good I'm in my
late 20s my girlfriend's in early 20s
we've been together for five years seven
years six years we've been talking about
moving in together getting an apartment
and maybe even getting married when
should we start sharing money when
should I start paying for their cars and
when should they start helping me with
my mortgage here's the deal if you've
been dating for six years five years
eight years make a decision make a
decision so here's what's so awesome I
dated my wife for five years I won't say
her name but she's sitting duck over
here they dated for five years
right there the guy holding the
microphone six years dudes make a
decision you know or you don't know okay
if you've been dating with somebody for
seven years five years and you're
thinking well we need to move into just
get married or call it number two never
put money in somebody else's pocket less
you're married okay and I know that
makes me sound I'm old-fashioned like
I'm an old they don't do it don't buy
somebody else a car unless you were
married don't start paying on somebody
else's mortgage unless you're married
unless you were joined together come
thicker thin you're gonna be in this on
the back end of it okay so to recap
don't talk bad about your husband your
wife your ex-wife your ex-husband don't
talk bad about the parents of your kids
don't do it whether you're still married
or not married
don't do that don't lean on your
children for your self-esteem and number
two Jess get married
ready this side you're gonna be in it
and go for it or do the hard thing and
just break up and move on but don't
start paying for somebody else's stuff
until you're bound together with
marriage I know that makes me feel like
an old man it's cool dude I am an old
man this is dr. John Delaney signing off
have a good week subscribe do the things
push the buttons and I will see you soon
take care